talk about Rick Perry.
Rick Perry was governor of Texas.
He's a Republican.
He's Donald Trump's secretary of energy and
he is an evangelical Christian through and
through.
And if you had any doubt about that,
he believes and he told Fox news that Donald
Trump was chosen or ordained by God to become
president and to do great things.
Now, if God chose Donald Trump, God either
has a very unusual sense of humor or is actually
an extraordinarily malicious actor.
Let's take a look at the video of Rick Perry
saying it in his own words.
God used imperfect people all through history.
King David wasn't perfect.
Uh, Saul wasn't perfect.
Solomon wasn't perfect.
Uh, and I actually gave the president a little
one pager on those old Testament Kings about
a month ago, and I shared it with him.
I said, mr president, I know there are people
that say, you know, you, you said you were
the chosen one.
Uh, and, and I said, you were.
I said, if you're a believing Christian, you
understand God's plan for the people who,
uh, rule and, and, and, and judge over us
on, on this planet, in our, in our government,
and less people on the left attack Rick Perry,
he pointed out to me, he believes Barack Obama
was sent by God as well.
He said for that moment and that time he said,
he thinks for this moment, this time, Donald
Trump was sent by God to do great things.
So we're gonna play the whole clip later.
But I think it's interesting now it's interesting
how ed Henry re
slips in that Perry also believes Obama was
selected by God.
But it's important because they're trying
to pretend to be fair and balanced here.
Trump was chosen by God to do great things,
says Rick Perry, which is very different than
why God would presumably choose Barack Obama.
According to Rick Perry's evangelical right
wing point of view.
Now this, uh, the, the analysis is this is
of course completely bonkers, but it is not
that rare among many of the people that are
around Donald Trump or supporting Donald Trump.
Trump is of course not at all religious.
He started pretending to be religious.
Uh, when he ran for president, his infamous
two Corinthians quote, um, claiming that the
Bible is his favorite book other than his
own book, art of the deal.
Uh, but as we know, um, we have seen this
exact, uh, idea that Trump is not only religious,
but was chosen by God, floated by a lot of
the people around Donald Trump.
One example is someone we already talked about
earlier on today's program, Trump's second
former press secretary Sarah Huckabee Sanders,
who said that God quote wanted Donald Trump
to become president.
And that's why he's there.
Secretary of state, Mike Palm PEO said that
it's possible God raised Donald Trump from
the beginning to be president in order to
protect Israel from Iran.
White evangelicals in general agree with this
idea.
In 2017, there was a survey done by the public
religion research Institute.
Um, and more than half of white evangelicals,
57% said that God played a major role in Trump
being elected president in 2016.
So there's actually a lot of stuff to dis-aggregate
here.
Number one, we know that 62% of Trumpists
will never turn on Trump no matter what he
does.
That's from a poll about three weeks ago.
Even hypothetically, there is nothing that
Donald Trump could do that would get them
to reconsider their support for Donald Trump.
I would guess that there's an overlap.
If you imagine a Venn diagram of the people
who think Trump was chosen by God and the
people who would never reconsider supporting
Donald Trump, that's 62% of his supporters.
If you believe Donald Trump was chosen by
God, of course you wouldn't turn on him no
matter what he does because whatever crazy
thing Trump does must be part of God's plan.
Again, it's obviously a closed logical loop
that is indefeasible.
There's no way to disprove it, but if that
is what you believe, that is logical reasoning
based on the completely bogus premises that
are required in order to get to that point.
That's number one.
Number two, as far as Trump goes, in terms
of his relationship to Christianity, Trump,
aside from it being an obvious lie that he's
a religious person.
Trump goes against essentially every stated
Christian belief.
Now stated as an important word, which I'll
come back to momentarily.
Trump is an adulterer.
He has been pro choice his entire life.
He's a liar.
He's a cheat.
He's been found legally liable for defrauding
both students and veterans on and on and on.
But what matters isn't whether you've actually
lived the life that adheres to the stated
evangelical Christian values or not.
What matters is, are you saying the right
stuff today?
And do you claim to be against abortion today?
And Donald Trump is the proof of this, that
uh, above all proof confirms this is the reality
for so many particularly white evangelicals
in the United States.
Donald Trump embodies the opposite of what
evangelicals claim to value, but he does say
he's against abortion.
Hillary Clinton was pro choice.
And this is basically all you need to know
in a great sense.
There's something insidious happening on the
American, right, which we haven't talked about
much.
The American right is generally considered
to fetishize the constitution almost as if
it were a sacred text.
But there is an extremist, evangelical Christian
contingent, I guess we would call it, where
sure the constitution is fine, but in reality,
they would prefer to do away with separation
of church and state and to make the United
States functionally a Christian theocracy.
They don't deify the constitution.
They would rather it be replaced with Christian
theology, a sort of Christian version of Sharia
law.
And that is a very, very scary thing.
And there's actually been a, there's a few
interesting documentaries recently, some fictionalized
and some TV series or, or films I would say
some fictionalized and some nod that point
this out and it is really, really scary stuff.
And Rick Perry's comment is just the, the
tip of the iceberg so to speak.